[Music]
we don't need to
consume animals to get our protein it's
harmful for the environment
and if we can build a product that
tastes as good as the animal
we're going to win food of the future
this week what if the whole world
went vegan we look into the impact of a
no meat no dairy lifestyle on people
and the planet yo i told my friends that
i'm gonna become a vegan
and live that plant-based diet and the
green alternative
pork from a petri dish edible insects
and impossible burgers
the big money behind fake meat it's not
surprising that it tastes like chicken
because it literally is chicken
plus the owner of pierre terre brings
vegan cuisine to his michelin star
restaurant
without wasting a single piece of food i
think
my children's my grandchildren will not
believe
you wet meat twice a day really i'm
emory hordern
and this is bloomberg green
[Music]
let's get your green and brief with
jennifer zavizadja
here's the climate news you need to know
this week
products boasting about their climate
credentials may not be as green as they
seem
according to global consumer watchdog
icepen
about 40 percent of environmentally
friendly claims
could be misleading it says this
greenwashing may be breaking the law and
comes at the expense
of genuinely environmentally friendly
products
one group the pandemic has helped south
africa's rhino population
due to restrictions the number lost to
poachers was down a third in 2020
for a sixth straight year of declines
but that's still
nearly 400 rhinos that were killed for
their horns then smuggled out of africa
climate change is causing sea levels to
rise faster than the most
pessimistic forecasts the revised
estimates from the ocean science
journal indicate that countries will
have to rein in their greenhouse gas
emissions
even more than expected to keep sea
levels in check
the uk needs to speed up its rollout of
charging points for electric vehicles
if it wants to hit its goals that's
according to the policy exchange think
tank it says britain will need to
install
35 000 a year up from just 7 000 now
to prepare for the ban of the sale of
new petrol cars
in 2030. and as we chart a course out of
the pandemic that economic recovery is
at the front of
everyone's mind but a focus on growth
could be bad for the environment
cambridge university economist partha
dasgupta says we should do away with gdp
and come up with a new measure that
takes into account our
impact on the environment and that's
your green in brief i'm jennifer
zabasaja in new york
anne marie so what would happen if we
all went vegan
well the u.n estimates the drop on
emissions would be monumental
preventing the release of eight gigatons
of carbon dioxide per year
and it's more than just a cultural
choice veganism is now big business
this year alone more than half a million
people signed up to the veganuary
campaign
so we took a look deeper at this growing
sector of the economy
chances are you're not a vegan but you
may have had an almond latte this week
or at least tofu in your ramen at some
point and even though a really small
number of people actually identify as
fully vegan
vegan products are filling up and flying
off
supermarket shelves that's because more
of us are now substituting meat and
dairy products with plant-based items
yo i told my friends that imma become a
vegan and live that plant-based diet
so i became a vegan i've been vegan
practically my whole life
i'm vegan is it a fad like so many other
food trends
or is it the start of something much
bigger this
is your bloomberg quick take on the
vegan economy
the vegan society was founded in 1944
in a bid to discuss non-dairy vegetarian
diets and lifestyles
you say it got a vegetable too much
meat's bad
it began and remained a very small
community for decades
but the animal alternative industry is
now expected to grow to 140 billion
dollars
in the next decade there's something out
there for anyone who wants to replace
any amount of animal product in their
diet from cheese or yogurt replacements
to bloody veggie burgers but since only
six percent of americans describe
themselves as vegan
this growth is coming from outside that
community
our meat-heavy diet doesn't just harm
animals it's killing our planet too
livestock farming produces about 14.5
percent of the planet's greenhouse gas
emissions
cows are the main offender rearing and
feeding farm animals leads to
deforestation which in turn
reduces our ability to absorb co2 in the
atmosphere
research from oxford university claims
that a vegan diet is probably the single
biggest way to reduce your impact on
planet earth
concern for the planet is one motivation
but over half of u.s adults who eat
plant-based proteins
said the main reason was taste meeting
concerns over diet
animal protection the environment and
health
vegan products are no longer the weird
dusty packets hidden in the back of the
health food shop
they're being delivered to the
mainstream by huge brands
like mcdonald's in burger king there's
even vegan beer
because as it turns out brewers use fish
guts for filtration
and the obsession with oat milk has led
to shortages in the us
causing hysteria across the country well
mainly brooklyn investors are now
getting in on the action
shares of beyond meat surged six hundred
percent in the three months after its
ipo
another plant-based burger maker
impossible foods raised 300 million
dollars
in the same month so what could hold
this burgeoning vegan economy back
nutritionists are questioning some of
the health credentials of these
processed meat alternatives
burger king's vegan burger the
impossible whopper contains a whopping
35 grams of fat and 1080 milligrams of
sodium
that's almost half of your recommended
daily allowance of sodium
others warn that genetically engineered
ingredients need more research to
determine their safety
despite the concerns there are bullish
signs traditional meat and dairy
companies like tyson and dean foods have
invested in plant-based products
with supposed benefits to our health
moving to a vegetarian and vegan diet
could produce
savings of up to a trillion dollars a
year on health care
and lost working days like it or not
humans are going to have to shift their
diets to help stem the tide of climate
change
with our planet's population growing the
vegan economy will need to win over even
more of us if it's to have a substantial
impact up next is the future of food
impossible from lab grown meat to pea
protein
burger patties we look deeper into the
innovations that are solving problems
from emissions to inequality this
is bloomberg green
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to bloomberg green i'm
anne-marie hordern now would you eat a
synthetic steak
or maybe chicken nuggets grown in a lab
no this isn't some
sci-fi hypothetical it's called cellular
agriculture
and companies around the world are
developing the technology to grow
artificial meat in vitro
now proponents say it's no kill no waste
method of making food
but whatever go mainstream maybe it
already has
[Music]
cultured or lab-grown meat was largely
confined to labs
until now singapore became the first
country in the world to allow the sale
of cultured meat
it gave eatjust the green light to sell
its lab-grown chicken nuggets
the san francisco company has now teamed
up with a restaurant 1880
it's put lab-grown chicken on its menu
making it the world's first restaurant
to serve up cultured meat
joining us now is josh tetrik he's a
co-founder and ceo
of eat just now josh this meat is
made from animal cells but doesn't
involve slaughtering any animals
how does that actually work we identify
a cell from a chicken
nutrients to feed their cells so instead
of eating storing corn we identify
nutrients for the cells
and then we culture scale it up um
in a large steel vessel and the process
is
somewhat like culturing beer and the end
of the
the process you have chicken meat or
beef meat in our case it
is chicken meat the simplest way to
think about it
is it allows all of us to consume meat
the good part the nutritional
composition
uh the taste and do away with the bad
part
which is the killing the environmental
deforestation
the acceleration of zoonotic disease
and we can still have fried chicken now
what are the advantages
of cultured meat versus regular meats
the advantages of cultured meat over
conventional meat include
safety so if you look at pathogens like
e coli
salmonella this way of making meat is
just
significantly cleaner more sanitary this
way of making meat radically decreases
the probability of
zoonotic diseases through our food
system if you look at climate change
this way of making meat is 90
more carbon efficient than the typical
approach
and if you look at something that maybe
is even deeper than that the morality of
how
we want to eat food we don't need to eat
food that causes harm
and but this way you don't have to call
us on does it
taste the same and the most common
reaction is
this tastes like chicken it has a flavor
profile
it has a texture of chicken and it's not
surprising that it tastes like chicken
because it literally is chicken and how
does it compare to
regular chicken in terms of cost we're
pricing it at right about premium
chicken so 1880 the place that we're
fortunate to launch with
uh a chicken dish is somewhere between
23 and 30 dollars and we're right right
in that range in terms of costs um
we are because of the proprietary nature
of how we're producing it we're not
sharing costs i can tell you we're not
making money on it right now
but as we continue to scale up as
economies of scale begin to take hold
we see a pathway in the next five or so
years to get
below the cost of chicken and that's
really where things begin changing
is there anything we haven't talked
about already that you want people to
know about cultured needs
young people see pretty clearly they
realize that we don't have to
bring harm onto our plate right we can
eat in a way that reflects
who we are the youngest person i know my
niece june who's two years old
by the time she enters high school i
want her to live in a world where the
vast majority of me
beef chicken all of it doesn't require
killing a single animal
doesn't require tearing down a single
forest
doesn't require a single drop of
antibiotics
and we want to run towards that world
for more resident green expert akshat
rothi joins us now
thanks so much for joining us so at the
end there he touches on the fact that
his niece is two years old
and when she goes to high school he
expects this to be the norm
how marketable is lab grown need i think
if
plant-based foods are any indication
there's clearly a hunger
for people to eat cleaner healthier
and guilt-free foods and so it feels to
me if you're going to be able to buy
cultured meat that is like meat but
doesn't come with the guilt or the
environment
environmental impact then that's a good
idea but is this scalable
it's a tricky challenge we know that
since 2009
uh these companies have had something
like 16 billion dollars
invested in them and now we are starting
to see
a product come to the market right so it
is complicated
but clearly even if the product is here
and is slightly expensive
it's here that means that other types of
products are probably
coming soon and and we can hope that you
know technology scales up
another big industry that
the whole green world is looking at is
insect farming and
making insect protein bars as robert
downey jr we're saying we're going to do
in six months time have a taste test
but there's this like ick factor
associated
with that he was quite cheeky and
optimistic i was a little bit more
reserved i think i might
i might would potentially go for it
europe's at the forefront of this
is this something we could really see i
would very happily eat tasty insects
right
we should recognize food and culture are
very connected
and there are lots of cultures that do
eat insects today
of course if you want to make it an idea
that is worldwide accepted
we're going to have to work through it
and we may not
always cross all the barriers but insect
protein has used outside of human
consumption
you can use it for feed for animals or
even fish
okay also the other thing is that the un
has focused on
insects and edible insects since for
over a decade really and not so much for
climate change
but for food security how do the two
overlap
so we know that as climate change has
impacts around the world
one of the biggest impacts is going to
be how people grow food and where
they grow that food so uh with warming
temperatures
the yields of certain types of crops are
going to decline and we're going to have
to support
farmers to produce the kind of food that
would be
adapted to that temperature rise and we
are not quite there
so uh with farmers being in most
countries among the
the poorest uh it's going to be not just
an
issue of food security but also of
inequality
and that's another reason why we should
have an alternative
in lab-grown foods all right another
alternative also for the record akshat
rati there our green expert will eat
insects as long as they're tasty but if
you aren't sold on insects or lab-grown
meat
how about plant-based alternatives the
market for fake meat is growing rapidly
and we spoke earlier to impossible foods
president dennis woodside
we don't need to consume animals to get
our protein it's
harmful for the environment and if we
can build a product that tastes as good
as the animal
we're going to win but that product has
to be priced properly
and so over the last year our footprint
in retail has grown from about 200
stores to 17 000 stores
our production's up nine fold over the
last 18 months or so
so with that scale we're getting
efficiencies in our production system
we're seeing lower unit costs and we're
passing those on to consumers and that's
our strategy
your strategy probably also the strategy
of a few other
competitors when it comes to the faux
meat avenue i'm looking at
of course beyond meat but they've been
having big roll outs for example
in some of their fast food chains how
much are you seeing
meat as the key competitor when it comes
to price but also the other
fake meats on on the market yeah so
we absolutely are competing with the cow
uh 80
of our consumers in retail are switching
from another animal meat product
and 11 are new to the categories they're
not buying
in the fresh meat aisle at all so we we
really don't
our business is not growing because
people are switching from other
plant-based
uh products they're switching from from
the animal product because
our products delicious it's better for
you no cholesterol lower saturated fat
lower calories
and people are more and more aware of
the impact of what they eat on the
environment
we're betting that eventually we're
going to have to price at the same price
as commodity-based beef right right now
even with these price reductions we're
in the range of organic grass-fed beef
which is a good market but the vast
majority of the market
is priced lower than that so as we scale
up we're going to have to keep moving
prices down
it's exciting this game though coming at
a time where
the us economy faces significant
pressure we're coming out
and still within a health crisis it's an
economic crisis it's a
it's particularly also a social crisis
in terms of being able to
target all spectrum of people who want
to buy
do you think your price is low enough to
ensure that those who are feeling the
economic impact right now can afford it
yeah i mean in some places we've
actually done a good job of getting our
price to be competitive so burger king
for example
burger king is a affordable place for
that anybody can eat
a white castle as well so we have lots
of outlets to get
our product out there at at reasonable
prices it was really important for us to
lower the price
in grocery stores because that's where
the vast majority of
americans are going to buy their meat
and so this is a step in the right
direction again it's not
the end point the end point is going to
be to get down to that
what we call 80 20 ground beef price
which is your commodity beef
that's that's some time away but each
time that we see these advantages in
scale and we start seeing our margins
grow
we're going to pass that along to
consumers
coming up the restaurant bringing vegan
food to the very top
table my interview with owner of
michelin starred pieterter
next this is bloomberg green
[Music]
the responsibility of companies is first
to reduce
their carbon footprint we also want to
exit coal and there's obviously a
consequence to it
and we do see the shifts obviously also
in the natural gas market
hydrogen and the promise of hydrogen is
not new
it can be a fuel secondly to report
and by report they mean not just saying
what they've done but what they
intend to do we know what it's going to
take to achieve those carbon emissions
and we'll be at the table having a
conversation
we've seen over it's now over 1200
companies major companies around the
world have signed up
for net zero uh plans we're developing a
lot of technologies that are supporting
the environment
and that are going to be needed for the
green deal in europe but also
for um the the plan that is being
developed at this point in time in the
us
we're very much looking forward to
working with the with the new
administration
uh on their energy and and their climate
agenda it's great to see their focus
specifically on offshore wind
um our 4.4 gigawatt joint venture with
equinor
i think will only grow in america over
the coming years and we're
looking forward to to building on that
welcome back to bloomberg green i'm
amber horder london's pierretera
celebrates its 30th anniversary this
year
the famous fitzrovia restaurant opened
its doors in 1991 received a michelin
star just 13 months later
and has been on the list ever since but
like many other eateries the pandemic
turned to the business upside down
pierretera adapted by providing a
delivery service
that rocked the boat again by making the
entire menu vegan
i spoke to owner david moore and asked
him why
vegan is something that is solidly here
to stay if you've got any common sense
at all
you've got to get on this story now i
didn't want to be somebody who's jumping
on a bandwagon in five years
saying okay yeah we're going to put a
vegan menu on i did the vegan menu
because the morning interests me
it brings a different clientele it
brings in a much younger a very big
lgbt crowd a grooviest like funkier
younger crowd it's also
menu fatigue for the customers regulars
who i know are not vegans
will come in and have the vegan menu
keeps the kitchen and
the chefs energized having to think
slightly outside of the box but the home
delivery was different
home delivery was because i couldn't see
delivering
the puritan food which is quite it's
very showy it's very
finessed that jumping around in a box in
the back of somebody's bicycle for half
an hour
i didn't see it landing on anyone's
plate in any good
shape or form let's do something that
nobody has any expectations of
so i came up with the vegan well every
restaurant even michelin star will have
to
have a vegan tasting menu if they want
to continue
being profitable and attracting the
clientele it's a number that i've not
heard before but there are over 125
vegan restaurants in london which was a
figure that surprised me i heard the
other day
you can see it going mainstream there's
lots of big players opening
what is the reason for this are a lot of
them health conscious or are they more
climate conscious i think
they're more conscious don't think that
i could tell you if they were
climate versus animal but they're all
tied up together they weren't there as
well
i think my children's my grandchildren
will not believe you wet meat twice a
day
really i think it's going to change
seismically
in the next couple of decades the vegan
food will become more interesting
is it as expensive to create a full
vegan meal
there is some discussion about margins
if we look at it
pound for pound the produce is cheaper
but there does tend to be greater input
in the kitchen so
my reason for charging the same is we
have more man-hours going into the dish
than we would with a protein a piece of
fish comes in
and you might pay five or six pounds for
it and it's ready to go
steam it you pan fry it and then you add
your garnishes when it comes
to a vegetable we have a lot more work
to turn that into a main course
and it's not just the dishes you serve
you actually have a very sustainable
supply chain can you walk us through
what that looks like
all our suppliers are known to us and
and have been for years
i started thinking that maybe that land
that we have on the menu
shouldn't be coming from the pyrenees it
should be coming from wales
if we have look on the menu the farmer
is fred he's out near chester
the beef comes from richard vaughan in
gloucestershire if it's
hand-dyed scallops or longer steams
that's coming from
the guys up in scotland at celtic we
know all our suppliers
we know how they look after the animals
and the animal husbandry is extremely
important not just because my conscience
but also
better the animal is looked after the
better the quality of the meat
how do you create vegan food on a
michelin star level
just doing the food that we do and we
get a michelin star for doing that
we cook our ditches and the chef
asimakis
he has a standard and an interest level
he wants to create
interesting food it's not something that
we're consciously thinking what would a
michelin
specter think of this we're doing dishes
that we find interesting
and also challenging for this dish to
work every time
it's going to be so precise and you
don't use meat substitutes
i don't believe that vegan food should
look like a chicken burger
should look like a hot dog because if
you want if you're thinking of eating a
hot dog just eat a hot dog
don't make something that looks like a
hot dog out of lentils
that's not my style plant-based food
that looks like plant-based food
that's it for this edition of bloomberg
green but keep the conversation going
follow us at climate i'm emery hordern
and this
is bloomberg green